foreign
good morning
we have
um
a work session scheduled uh a public
hearing on a non-germaine Amendment and
then originally the plan was to do an
executive session right after that and I
wanted to announce for everyone here
just in case you're in the obvious
audience for that exact session that we
will not be doing an executive session
today I apologize for that what we'll do
is we will schedule it for next Tuesday
which I believe is May 9th so if you're
interested in any of those bills that we
have left to exec we're going to move
that to next Tuesday to allow us to be
better prepared
I don't know what time I saw it probably
will be closer to 11 A.M because we also
have a request from someone who has a
medical appointment so we're trying to
work around that next week the one that
we must exec is an early bill and I
believe that's Senate Bill 120 that we
might be ready to do others at that time
but but we'll get together then so
representative ulery
no execs today so if you're here and
you're you're here for that reason then
you can go home and
make another breakfast or something
because you were here early yes
representative um um because I urge uh
this to actually be on Wednesday versus
Tuesday or the only Pro that problem is
a problem because we're now getting very
very close to the deadline so we could
do both maybe but I I'm I hate to wait
to the absolute last minute on an early
Bill deadline if that's okay
I think I might have to have a
replacement but uh Tuesday I can't make
it but okay let's
um representative plett did you have
something yeah I'm wrong or we start
early on the night you want to start
early on the ninth now
um could everyone be here closer to 9
A.M on Tuesday I just need a point of
order yes I have I rescheduled an
appointment that they will not
reschedule again for three which means I
leave here at 1 30 and I think the rule
is you have to be here all day to be in
the exact so just to be a matter of fits
in the morning I could do it okay so
you're talking about next Tuesday yes
okay could people be here at 9 00 a.m
ish on next Tuesday does that work
yes okay good we'll try to get our
business done between nine a.m and what
time did you need uh 3 15. oh okay so
between 9 and 1 30. right should give us
the time we need
thank you so much for your accommodation
I really appreciate that okay with
without further Ado we will open up the
work session on Senate bill 112.
and oh we haven't really structured
anything for this but I believe
representative almi had an amendment she
may wish to discuss
and have some technical questions
I don't believe I've seen any other
amendments on Senate bill 112.
for the Republican benefit the
Republican caucus because well I've
talked to all but one of the Democratic
caucus uh yesterday uh in a zoom uh
there are complications behind 112 but I
see
on
having to do with what seems to be the
the principal purpose of the sponsor
uh Senator
Richard uh
which is to
um assemble more money for problem
gaming
and get it to the lottery
and
um that is as
the executive director knows I'm quite
sure on but the rest of us I think have
forgotten or never knew
there is on on the bill that did sports
betting they also created a council for
responsible gaming and instead of
putting it in the lottery section they
put it in the Commerce part of our laws
and so it's
um
and it's been ramping up and apparently
is going to start doing some good stuff
now
um but it was pretty quiet
on the internet I found no no that was
the other group there is a group that's
been around a lot longer
perhaps Charlie knows uh when they got
started but the Council on problem
gaming
which is a non-profit on run by a
three-person board I think it looked
like only two of them were active
um
which has been receiving the money for
problem gaming from Lottery
uh
on a regular basis and is now two of two
of the board are on the the five-person
board of the responsible gaming
uh the responsible gaming money comes
from an administrative expense of the
lottery
and
um is
on appropriated to them
in the in the lottery Appropriations in
the budget
and it can be up to two hundred and
fifty thousand
the for the startup they gave them a
hundred thousand lately they've been
giving them uh well lately no in the
next budget they will be getting 250 000
a year
and um
the executive director could probably
explain better than I could what it's
for but it sounds
like they are going to be working with
the mental health centers around New
Hampshire uh in developing programs
within them specifically to problem
gaming to to gambling addiction which
um
is and then the other two people on it
are from Cambridge Massachusetts
I wasn't quite sure if it was came
Cambridge England but
they they are professors I believe and
they research on gambling there
so um
it's um that so that group gets in a
direct appropriation in the budget and
they're administratively under the
lottery but the lottery doesn't uh I
think do
a lot of work with them
um and
the other group
might end up somehow
merging with this one or disappearing on
and
um that group has also I hadn't realized
until yesterday from lbao on on been
getting money from from the lottery
in a different way somehow but the
lottery was charged in a number of
places in the statutes without giving
them money for it on with doing
something about problem gaming
when every time somebody put a new form
of gambling in they uh they were told
you ought to do something about problem
gaming
so
um
the question is my the amendment that I
was putting forward was to take all of
this
um was to take the money from this bill
paramutual racing and historic
horse racing
um
into a dedicated fund so that it would
be more visible
and ability more somewhat more ability
to figure out what they were doing
but that was before I knew all about
this stuff
and I think now the situation is more
complicated we need discussions Lottery
Counsel on problem gaming on
on the and the people interested from
this committee and
um in adding a pudding instead
this could pass as it as it is and I
think not mess things up
but
um and and then that part of it be done
but then we need to figure out
how how those agencies and the money
flowing to them
gets put together in such a way that the
money that
Senator ricciardi wanted to send to them
doesn't just replace part of the money
that's already going to them
but also would
not be frugaled away and I'm sure that
the executive director is on top of this
in some ways
so
so that's what I wanted to say
would it be helpful to hear from Lottery
of what what is going on with these
funds would you be available
Mr McIntyre
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
Charlie McIntyre I have the privilege of
being the director of New Hampshire
lottery
um
originally when
I believe was Keno was passed there was
a separate fund created
in HHS to address problem gaming and
that fund was funded by certain parts of
Aquino revenues
HHS didn't do anything with it for
several years
and so that fund grew to be I think it
was eight hundred thousand dollars
and it just sat there and nothing
happened nothing happened and um
Governor sununu through his budget
office then created the council for a
problem responsible gambling that was
initially tied to us thinking we would
move faster and do things faster
um it is a bit
um
it's a bit difficult as you can imagine
being
the chief bookie and then also having
administrarily tied the problem gambling
Council it's it's you know it's it would
be characterized into professions as
bipolar
um and so I
we they're initially tied dust car so
under the current law they're
administrarily tied to us so we help
them with things like purchasing and
budgeting procurement they use our
office space they use our facilities
their copy machines Etc
um but I don't have anything to do with
them as you can imagine I'd love to do
it but it doesn't make any sense it
would look unseemly uh and so there's
funding sources obviously as
representative Albany suggested but
unless it's similarly budgeted if we
make more like for example if this bill
passed and breakage was a million
dollars the remaining 750 would not go
to problem gambling it would go to the
general fund because it was budgeted for
two fifty thousand dollars and so
um that's has been the case for a number
of years of the revenue sources that
exists now and certainly as the person
who is in charge of regulating and
operating gambling in the state
um I would be delighted to help in any
way possible to promote more services
the council is now reaching out to train
essentially trainers in addressing
problem gaming
um it's a very small percentage of
people but it affects their lives deeply
it ends up being about one half percent
of the two percent of people who gamble
have a problem and I'll Define that let
me know air quote that it's that they
have an issue
um and need need services so
um that's the history of the where it is
now it is like I said initially tied to
us there are a number of groups have
only said there are a couple of
professionals who have done this as
I believe they were psychologists uh
professors they were certainly educated
uh who have done it now the council the
executive director is a former
Massachusetts correctional officer who
himself was a problem Gambler and he
lives in New Hampshire now he grew up in
Fall River
um and he runs it and he actually will
answer calls from people on his cell
phone so folks who have a problem will
call and the council gets maybe a few
dozen calls a month from people who have
issues and they try to match those folks
with services so that's it in a nutshell
uh representative Platt yes this is
directed to uh representative almi uh do
have we got a copy of that amendment
that you had
no it isn't
that
and what I understand it needs changing
anyway after discussion
um
but could I ask him a question first and
then we get to the procedural issue
it's a work session tour a little more
let's see great thank you uh does that
it sounds like what that is is if
breakage gets above 250 you're taking
money that was supposed to be going to
the ETF
and sending it to the general fund
no it goes to education trust fund all
of our revenues are by yeah you said g g
s oh I did I'm sorry my apologies I've
been misspoke it's the education trust
fund
thank you
okay did you found it okay
thank you all right and just to get back
to representative Almy are you happy
with this amendment as is
I am happy with this amendment as is on
the thing that I'm wondering about as I
understood representative plant was
trying to work on each wager
that language
the redistribution of each wager instead
of based on each dollar wage wagered
and so I thought there were going to be
two amendments we were looking at
representative plett do you have
Amendment on this bill
I have the one that she said it was in
front of me and it was
one of yours one of mine yeah what did I
do you're going to work on on the the
whether we should
why we should change based on each
dollar wagered to of each wager no no
who said that then
oh
did you work on it would would it be
possible first since we first started
with representative almie's Amendment
could you walk us through the whole
thing just so we fully understand it and
we can ask you questions and then if
it's appropriate then maybe
representative fellows you can tell us
about your thoughts
I was just answering my question about
where that came from but I think we have
kind of like two totally different
issues going on here one of them is we
started kind of with a discussion of
what's going on with the problem
gambling and the money related to that
and then the the other issue in in my
mind is the language that we have about
breakage because from what I have been
able to learn and I you know I did some
research is that the language in both
the bill and in rules about breakage
doesn't
um
does not reflect
how breakage is actually calculated and
and probably but I don't know for sure
what's actually occurring with the
breakage
so those to me are sound like two
totally different issues I think we
should do one at a time
yes I agree two totally different issues
in here and hopefully we can sift
through that I have heard there is
ongoing problems with that language on
breakage
so it may be something that has to be
worked on more than just a day
so we'll see about that and then maybe
this bill turns into something else I
don't know I don't know because we'll
have to see so do you want to walk us
through your Amendment
uh yes it's uh it's easier referring to
my yellow
piece because on they read as usual they
redid the whole thing and so it's hard
to tell what the original Bill changed
and what I changed but the first piece
of it is on line 19.
8 19 no eight
uh no 19
um sorry
no I don't have numbers on my 22 on
where
where does this thing it looks to me
like the first change you're making is
on line 2223 of the amendment oh yeah
there it is thank you on I'm
um
what I did was to
add take out
and used his payment
and said instead
both of them say paid to the Lottery
Commission I took out as used and used
as payment and I replaced it with to be
deposited in the problem gaming fund
under RSA
284-22c which I create at the end
um
and really most of this except for that
part at the end is
um doing exactly the same thing in the
others the next one is line six on page
two
takes out and use this payment adds in
to be deposited in the problem gaming
fund under RC 284-22c
and then the third one is
in
Roman 4.
um
on line 20
on takes out and uses payment and
replaces it with to be deposited in the
problem gaming fund under RSA 284 22c
then when you get to Historic horse
racing
um
which
it um yeah line
30 yes uh it it takes out and used as
payment well I guess that's exact almost
the same thing and used as payment for
problem gaming services and it instead
says paid to the Lottery Commission to
be deposited in that fund and uh then
there is a new section
at the end
on
after section 22 B
which creates section 22c problem gaming
fund and that's found on page three in
the amendment
and
it defines it as provided providing
funding for the identification and
treatment of problem game gamblers
non-lapsing continually appropriated
to the Lottery Commission
and the fund shall receive all the
monies from breakage under everything
that is in this bill
um and then it creates which is where I
started it creates a 612 uh
notation so that the problem gaming fund
is in the list of
dedicated funds
um
and when you do a dedicated you add a
dedicated fund they always give it
sub paragraph
387 would be the next one since last
year
but there may be three different ones
coming in and
um in enrolled bills they would change
the 388 to whatever number it comes up
to be there are about
120 I think
dedicated funds that we have repealed
since we started doing enumeration
it used to be alphabetical
uh
and so we really don't have 387 in
existence right now but it's up there
yeah so that that's that's what I was
doing and so can I just ask though so
right now we all we already have
a problem gaming fund effectively or for
the course they have two in the state
what
uh they're talking right now but um what
happened to the 400 000 odd dollars that
were sitting in HHS
and not being used that that uh Mr
McIntyre told us about okay just now
so this is the kind of thing that that
bothers me in I in dedicated funds that
we're always needing to try to you know
get different things that different
people were doing at different times
and put them together in the same place
if they're trying to do the same thing
and one of them isn't doing anything
yeah
Madam chair yeah
on Mr McIntyre we were getting in the
Weeds on this uh problem gaming fund
question and uh so this amendment would
make a new problem gaming fund to deal
with all the breakage as mentioned in
this bill
what so can you update us on that money
that was in the other fund because what
we don't want to end up having is three
different funds yeah doing you know
we're trying to figure this out the HHS
fund so that fund actually was never
expended and dropped at the bottom line
as a transfer to the education trust
fund oh it did correct yes and
fundamentally there'd be no need to send
a fund you could just literally have an
expense on our bottom line for problem
gambling and we would just spend it
there's no need for it obviously it's
your prerogative but a dedicated fund is
unless you don't want to make change the
nature of the funds because obviously if
it didn't spend the year would lapse so
but
um if you change the budget to increase
or that amount it would be would
obviously set it aside and spend it
right so that's one of the questions is
do we really want it to be non-lapsing
if it's never spent for a couple of
years while people are figuring out what
it's needed for well fundamentally that
was the problem at first there's no
question it was not used it went to HHS
which obviously had a very large
construct and had difficulty creating a
separate
small thing so yeah but now it is
actually active and is spending funds
and providing Services although limited
um so yes it would be expended
uh represent homie did you have more to
add on that no I think I okay
representative thanks
thank you madam chair
um
I guess one question I have is
how big
how big is breakage because of breakage
if all breakage is going into this fund
I mean is it is it too much yes so I
guess
do we have any idea so the question is
we've actually think of the question
representative we've literally discussed
in that when I was seated back with my
colleague
um currently it would just be around 250
ironically
um it would be our expectation that that
number would grow
based on historical expressing
increasing revenues monthly and new
facilities coming online so I think it
would be just about what you would is
budge in the budget now
um but it would be larger and next
fiscal year and thereafter
representative fellas
I'm I'm still not clear on when you're
talking about HHS what are you talking
about sure
um representative the
when Kina was originally passed in 2000
and
16 17.
the sale of keynote tickets
um a percentage of the revenues was
dedicated towards a problem gambling and
that money was set aside in a fund that
was administered by HHS
they never did anything with it the
number the fund just grew and continued
to grow and so it was just a
a growing fund and so when it
transferred to us
that those funds dropped to our bottom
line is a transfer it went to the
education trust fund as essentially
revenues of the lottery and so now
the funding of the problem gambling
commission or council is done through
the lottery as an expense of ours
okay so really that's that is not in the
picture currently correct so so my my
real question here has to do with
um the amount of money going to
problem gambling issues and
if it's gonna if the amount is going
going to increase you know what what
does it really need to increase because
what exactly is going on so one of the
things I did I did some research and I
first of all to help everybody
understand there are two New Hampshire
councils related to gambling and one of
them's called is New Hampshire Council
on responsible gambling and that is a
commission that the members are
appointed by the governor
and then there's another one that's
called New Hampshire Commission on
problem Gam
excuse me
so the second one is called New
Hampshire Commission on problem gambling
and that's a non-profit institution and
that the um the commission for
responsible gambling
doesn't really I mean they meet but they
have a to get the work done they have a
contract with the commission on problem
gambling which is the non-profit
so I looked at reports about what's
going on with that in the expenditures
and I looked at their website which had
minimal information one of the things it
did is it listed
places where you could go to Gamblers
Anonymous meetings only one was in New
Hampshire the other ones were in Maine
and Massachusetts
on one page I looked at it and there was
a link on I guess their Partners down at
the bottom that said drug and alcohol
and I clicked on that and it went to
some sort of ad for gambling
which is means the website I don't know
been hacked or sounded I'm sure that was
not the intent
it's I don't know some kind of hacking
or something went on with that which is
like you know that that would be very
some people would think that would be
very funny obviously
so I'm just concerned that and I looked
at some of the minutes of the meetings
and their you know they get calls from
Maybe
15 people with gambling problems
over a couple of months and it just if
we're going to put more money in this I
think maybe there should be some more
specifications
on how it's used and and also the fact
that one person is on both of these
councils and I've never heard of a
situation where a council would have
be responsible for a contract
with the person that's on the council it
just it seems irregular to me
these are my concerns certainly so
they're administratively tied to us and
so I don't I don't we don't manage them
I have no responsibility as you can
imagine because of the in both of them
literally what comes the problem we just
make the money in this context and and
suspended and our CFO reviews their
expenditures our chief compliance
officer helps them with Contracting and
permit uh not permitting but if there's
a a council matter like the executive
Council matter that does the
so if you ask questions about their
operations you're gonna have to ask the
the them
yeah and you know we don't want to grill
the director here but um maybe maybe
this is something we have to work on in
a different bill as representative almie
mentioned because and maybe we asked
those folks you know what the details
are representative fellows yes but the
the chair of the Council of
responsible gambling is an employee of
the lottery exactly yes so and that's
who when I wanted to see um a report
I called the number on the website and
that's where it went and she sent me the
report so how can you say you're not
involved
because her her role her role in there I
don't supervise her in that role quite
literally I do not supervise her as the
chair of the the council she handles it
as as she sees the best interest and
she's confirmed by the executive Council
and has been I think twice
so
all right this sounds like we might need
a different work session on the deeper
dive that and maybe invite some of those
folks to see if they'll join us I
representative Ames do you want to add
anything
just just a few words because I do agree
that this is really a separate
discussion that we need to pursue
um
and I absolutely support funding for
the prevention and
and help directed towards those who
might or do engage in problem gambling
and I also want to commend the director
of the lottery for supporting that as
well throughout his career and I know
that from the time when I chaired the
gaming
New Hampshire gaming commission back in
maybe
and not only you but Ed Talbot who is
the person that has been mentioned
indirectly but not by name
who himself is a recovered or recovering
I don't know what the right lingo is but
a man who experienced serious problem uh
gambling and its effects and who has
persevered through all of this time
working on this issue and finding tow
hos here and there to keep going and I
know he was very helpful to to me when I
did my work at that time so
um yes uh we need the funding that's one
issue we need to be sure the funding is
properly used and that's another issue
and I think it would help all of us
because problem gambling keeps popping
up as we deal as the sole Committee in
the house
responsible for gambling with
this question of problem gambling and it
keeps cropping up in the statutes as
representative Alma has noted with
different language I noticed that in
this bill uh it's it's money for problem
gambling which is a strange way of
putting it and then in representative
omni's language is for the
identification treatment of problem
gambling
and if I were writing it I would have
added prevention
as another funded activity
but it's something we need to focus on I
guess it's what I'm I'm pointing to
um if we pull back to this bill that's
in front of us
um and the question of allocating
breakage to it
um
I think we could go forward although I'm
now pausing because of this question of
is it too much money or too little and
maybe it's better to just do it by
appropriation which is where it's landed
right now it goes through the House Bill
one appropriation process House Bill 1n2
and uh
and maybe that's where judgments are
made about how much money is needed and
how much has been spent that's part part
of the budgeting process and uh it would
be an expense item and part of the
review would be whether it's
sufficiently independent of the lottery
so maybe it's in just the right place
and maybe we can discuss this uh we
don't need a separate allocation of the
breakage but I kind of like seeing that
happen and
um I'm just not sure about that
so uh I don't know where that leads us
but that's sort of a
uh expressing my thoughts on an issue
that's evolving as we sit here
so I can make two points manager I know
I'm a member of the house I wanted to
make two points which I thought would be
relevant um first I think I originally
gave the council the idea for a
dedicated fund because when I was a
Damascus when I was Mass lottery I was a
general counsel there and I wrote the
language that's permanently funded them
because their budget had been cut to
zero and so they got a specific an
account from the Mass lottery revenues
that was dedicated for life and was not
lapsing so the I think the idea came
from us but me personally so I apologize
um second
um when the council was originally
funded back with Keno revenues at the
time our revenues from all gambling was
around 70 million this year to be 180.
so if you if the problem was X in
2015-16 it's probably more than that now
so I would suggest the funding it
over funding it probably isn't a problem
it sounds like there's a lot more to
discuss on the the fund itself how it's
structured and so forth
um should we maybe go back to talking
about the breakage definition do we have
any experts here including the director
yeah on the breakage definition so as I
as I was leaving the room I realized
what the question was representative
fellows had and and the answer so and I
apologize for as usual Murphy's Law
having it too late so all horse racing
is based on a two dollar wager
you go if you go to a tote board you
know the board's a two dollar wager and
so what you get paid off of that is on
the board so if the horse that you bet
on say wins 340 you win your bet on a
two dollar bet times 340. so if you bet
ten dollars you win thirty four dollars
and the breakage would have come off of
that through as I understand it the
breakage would have come off at 3.40
well multiplied 10 times so you don't
get
that makes sense
so
um representative did you have a
question yeah you do your math just
escaped you said it was a two dollar bet
correct so representative fellows used
the analogy of a ten dollar bet or ten
times Ben yeah okay
um but so it's really five times the
three dollars and forty cents or ten
times the 3.40
bubbled it for a five times the 340
right correct it's five times you would
win
17 or seven no yeah 17 but you did a
break would you come off of the three
dollars and forty cents if say the
actual winning amount was 3.41 you would
get five pennies would go to breakage
and 340 would go to winning says I
understand it
I see some hands up representative ulery
so you're telling us that this is the
only industry where breakage is
profitable
I I don't know that I don't know that to
be the case I
there's a hole underneath my chair on
the floor I would just give you the
money back with my salary if I don't
have to define a breakage again but
representative fellows I just want to
say that Rick Newman explained it to me
you know since since we met the last
time in right
and and he went step by step and I
understood it completely but it it needs
to to
for me to grasp it it needed to slow
down a little and go step by step so we
might want to consider that yeah if
someone could maybe I don't know draw it
out on a diagram or something so we can
understand how this actually match
that's an excellent excellent suggestion
I will I will send you a page definition
by the close of the business this week
explaining breakage and how it works
both for
I know this sounds odd but horse racing
which is easier than a store course
racing which is a slightly more
complicated believe it or not but you'll
get a definition
and if there are any of the vendors that
do the historic horse racing can give us
any help on this too that would be
helpful because we're dealing with two
different correct and also it's going to
vary by vendor quite literally it's
going to vary by vendor so that's why
it's hard to find what works for
everyone
uh other hands over here on this side
yes represent a divorce thank you madam
chair and thanks for taking my question
so if I understood what you said whether
it's a two dollar wager or a 10 wager if
someone wins
3.43 three cents is the breakage if it
was a two dollar bet that means the
breakage gets six cents if it's a ten
dollar bet the breakage gets 30 cents
nope okay multiplied by five because it
would be based off of two dollars so
it'd be a three to four a three dollars
and forty Cent wager
would be the amount you would win off of
two dollars so you would I don't get
into odds making but it would be say
3.43 cents three cents would be breakage
I got the three cents right so how much
actually goes to breakage if it's a ten
dollar bet it would be 15 cents 15 cents
because it's five two dollar bets five
it's five shares of the wind pool
okay I I got that but I don't know if I
could explain it back thank you what's
up Prince Right
I think that's right yeah yeah
representative thank you madam chair uh
when some of us learn different ways
so when you send out your explanation
sheet if you could try to send give us
information in different ways such as
percentages as well as examples it would
certainly be helpful to me thank you
sure absolutely
representative oh me
thank you is it possible to do that for
horse racing and for the machines
on
with and without the change of language
from based on each dollar to of each
wage I believe so I certainly will give
it an effort yes thank you
okay great we've got another few minutes
other questions yes representative
spilsbury yeah this is a very minor
suggestion I wouldn't file an amendment
to do it but if we're rewriting this
uh online page uh one of the bill line
18 where it says multiple of 10
. I got the impression that this was
confusing and just adding the word sense
multiple of 10 of what it's the multiple
of 10 of the odd cents
so just putting the word sent in in each
of the four places that it occurs I
think would
eliminate some confusion
I apologize you're looking at the bill
itself right not the amendment
yes whether it's the bill or the
amendment because I didn't see okay got
it thank you so so it in each of these
four passages that are amended
phrase to the next lowest multiple of 10
ad cents four times
Mr McIntyre does that help or hurt do
you think
um I don't know I don't have the I don't
have the amendment in front of me not
the bill I'm sorry representative Madam
chair
if
with that yeah yeah I only see it in the
bill I don't see it in the amendment so
when you get a minute we have more time
on this bill
oh it is an amendment I couldn't find it
it's just maybe a different line the
amendment restates the same time okay
before with it so
representative leapley
my question doesn't have to do with
breakage so
Mr McIntyre has a response first and
then we go there
I'm sorry so do you what do you think
about adding the word sense to the Align
20 of the amendment does that make any
sense do you want to think about it
don't think about it please I just saw
it I and I don't yeah I just you know
this is really technical in terms of how
this is actually going to impact because
one of the difficulties is how
the it's the how the simulcast the
tracks Define breakage matters how it
comes in as well as how the
manufacturers of the machine Define
breakage so I don't want to overly limit
that and have to have them change
programming based off of it so you've
got hundreds of machines in the field
now all of which are programmed and
tested which is a very expensive process
each one has been to run through a lab
so I don't want to speak you know shoot
from the hip as it were about changing
how they would do programming and then
you'd have to pull several hundred
machines potentially off the field
retest them based off of new
requirements that's all
you understand the issue Madam chair I
believe I'm sure
representative you might want to
consider if you have to put in the two
dollars there because it's a wager of
that's computed on a wager of two
dollars correct that's traditional horse
racing I would have to confirm with the
manufacturers as to what's their
wagering basis is or what breakage is
defined by them
oh okay can I assume or maybe I
shouldn't assume anything anymore
um if if when you go to the racetrack
and when you're doing simulcast would it
be any different
um how would it be different I'd have to
check I have to check please
okay so staying with the breakage
concept other questions on breakage
representative ullery
just to follow up in the shipping
industry breakage and spoilage have
entirely different meaning than they do
here and that's what I was referring oh
okay oh oh certainly it does so in the
liquor business too so
okay
um representative
thank you
um I just wanted to reaffirm that I
think this is a really important issue
and that we need to make sure that it's
funded
um generously and in a way that will
grow as gambling in the state grows
um I'm sure lots of people here have
their own experience with this issue I
was a victim my family was a victim of
some of a gambler who like devastated
our finances and
um
his own life and the life of many people
around him and just in trying to
understand this issue listening to some
of the webinars looking around online it
sounds like we don't have a great handle
on who is gambling on the state in the
state how many gamblers there are
um but just if I were to put together
some numbers that I've heard and and
maybe you can correct me if you have
better information but one of the
um
webinars I was looking at last night
said that there were probably 65 000
gamblers in the state and
um certainly I have all those numbers in
my head as well as in data form various
ways okay you'd have to Define Gambler
right so sort of what they do and I
could give you the number as to how many
do it right so where I was going with
this and and I welcome you to to jump in
but I was starting to put together okay
if two percent of gamblers are problem
gamblers and there are 65 000 gamblers
in the state that's 13 000 people who
would have a problem with gambling
so it would be
that'll be 150th to 100. thirteen
hundred thank you I I that's I know a
lot of you have a math background so
thank you
um
so that's like 190
um per person if we're talking about 250
000 in an account right so I think it's
I'm really happy that we're spending
some real time thinking about this issue
um because as I looked around and
thought about what we were doing it it
almost appeared like what we're doing is
obviously the state advertises gambling
a lot right we're telling people they
should go gamble we're encouraging them
to go gamble we're spending money
encouraging people to gamble in the
state so I just want to be cognizant of
of that and
on the other hand like you said we're
also want to support people who have a
problem and it kind of seems like the
way we're supporting them right now is
really just I mean if we're talking
about a budget of 250 000 it's going to
be communication right it's going to be
a billboard that says hey call this
phone number hey call these people it's
not going to be actually paying for
mental health services for folks right
and the other thing I picked up as I was
reviewing this information last night is
76 percent generally not in New
Hampshire of people who have a gambling
problem also have a problem with drugs
or alcohol so it seems like it's a
pretty sophisticated Mental Health
Nexus of events
um that is going to require some sort of
support Beyond you know a fraction we're
gonna if we're going to spend a fraction
telling people
here's the hotline to call Gamblers
Anonymous we're going to spend one
percent of a budget doing that and you
know a million dollars
times I don't know what amount telling
people to go gamble
that doesn't seem very well thought out
so I'm glad that we're we're gonna stop
and think about how much money are we
dedicating to this and where's that
money going is it just going to make a
flyer to tell people like they can call
someone but there's actually no
support there and it does sound like
there are some real experts
um in the psych psychological field who
are doing research in this area who
understand
um this Nexus so it does sound like we
can consult with people and find out how
to do this well so I just wanted to
support
representative Ames comments that this
is is a really important issue and I'm
really glad we're spending time on it
and I hope that we will fund it
adequately and set it up so that it is
successful and overseen adequately so
thank you for dedicating the time to
this this morning
absolutely and representative Malloy
thank you uh
I wanted to
address
representative Leafly just said I think
we were watching the same
video
and I wrote down from that 65
000 were problem
gamblers that's what that I thought that
video said an 8 000 were pathological
did I hear that wrong or was that
uh okay I just wanted to put that out
there
that seems strange but I don't know I
don't know where you got that do you
know where who put that up
that that video was uh
sent
I I got that from uh representative Ames
and that was Mr Talbot that was uh uh Mr
Talbot who was okay I don't believe I
saw that email so thank you okay other
hands up yes representative Schaumburg
thank you madam chair uh uh just going
back to representative almi's Amendment
there is no problem with anyone here
about the words to be deposited changing
it from used as payment is there any
problem with those words by anybody here
well it doesn't matter it's all three uh
line six unrepresentative almi's
Amendment line 20 it changes the line 30
I just want to make sure we're just
going to be going to one other area when
we do go to the study the word to be
deposited is what representative almie
has said instead of and used as a
payment
on all all the lines
I just I'm just asking a question here
does
does anybody have an objection to what
she has written to be deposited versus
used as payment
from the original bill just seems clear
I'm sorry representative Southworth
which one seems clearer to you the
change made by a representative of Ami
the deposited yeah deposited just as
much more specific okay gotcha and
representative ulery I see a light yeah
two things not to follow up on this
immediately when you putting it into the
fund is established by 284-22c that is
what it the payment comes from so you're
that's fine you're absolutely correct I
would like to ask a question please
previously this breakage fund went as a
kind of an incentive to the game
operator is that correct sir
it was split three ways it was split uh
the operator us and State Treasury
okay
what if follow-up manager
what would be the effect on the stimulus
or the incentive but
incentivization of the uh game operator
would it have a deleterious effect on
operating these games or or how's that
going to work
I mean they would lose the revenues
simple as that in some states I think
breakage is 100 of the operator uh and
so it would be Revenue that would be
lost by the specific entity
um which was just Seabrook the star
course rating operators
have already had this baked in with them
in terms of breakage
um
I don't think they'd be a bit of post
but I'll check with them follow them up
again
so if we were to eliminate the incentive
we uh would disincentivize offering this
game to other individuals which then in
turn would reduce the amount of funds
going into the problem gaming uh
category I mean yes it's less profitable
for that thank you
okay representatively thank you madam
chair I just wanted to share the the
video that was referenced
um is available on YouTube it's New
Hampshire Council for responsible gaming
put it up and it's a conversation about
problem gaming prevention and treatment
in New Hampshire with members of the New
Hampshire Council on problem gaming
which is the other one and the New
Hampshire Council for responsible gaming
so both of them together participated in
video
okay representative only
I turn it on and it turns off
on
when we were dealing with the idea of a
major Casino we went into a lot of the
statistics and one of the things that
um we found out on was that the
addiction rate could rise near a major
Casino the people who lived near there
and could go daily to eight percent of
the gamblers so that may be where that
eight number came from
but
what
this would be doing
if we passed it on this uh
at this point would would simply be
taking all of that money and specifying
that there is a dedicated fund on
I called it the problem gaming fund just
out of something in my head from the
past I have no no I no no concern with
what it's actually called
um
but on it it would not be changing
anything else in this the thing that is
changing stuff is if we fool around with
what each wager is
senator elberger
thank you madam chair
um firstly just to respond to
representative Schamberg's question I
agree I like the language the way it's
it's presented now that very clear
funneling I'm not sure if you're asking
for that information but
um and to follow up on representative
leapley's comment about
um
problem risky risky behavior in one of
my earlier lives I was I ran alcohol and
later
drug abuse programs which were
at that time considered totally
different most of us know they're not
but it's clear that risky behaviors that
include gambling that include substance
misuse
smoking unprotected sex with multiple
partners
um
driving ridiculously fast in bad places
to do that tend to
be connected uh
and it might be worth not instead of
this but at some point to consider
trying to set up some kind of
commission or organization to address
the whole notion of risky Behavior
when I was working in the field the it
was clear that the gateway drug which
many people thought was marijuana was
not but in fact was tobacco
uh and it was the the most simple
predictor of further substance misuse so
all of those things are connected
thank you
representative I'm not sure who had the
hand up first representative fellows I
apologize I was taking notes
I thank you ma'am cheer I I just have
one idea and then I have two technical
questions so my idea is that in terms of
how we split the breakage when once we
figure out how much that is that it
doesn't have to be the same for a track
or simulcast or the HHS machines just
not to discuss now but just the idea
that it could be doesn't have to be the
same for all of them and my questions
had to do with I I saw I saw an ad on TV
and it was for sports betting and they
were talking about the Kentucky Derby so
can you tell me is it is can you know I
was thinking that horse racing would be
under these laws but I saw something on
the ad on TV uh so uh think of the
question the we don't currently accept
horse racing Wagers through our sports
betting platform
there'd have to be some kind of Statute
change to do that so there's another
bill pending before you called Advanced
deposit wagering which
sort of corrects So currently the status
is there are operators taking wagering
on horse racing over mobile and internet
that we do not regulate they're doing it
currently there are a few operators that
do that I don't believe they advertise
on TV but I do know that they will send
emails and they'll like we don't
regulate them currently there's a bill
um before you to to bring them under the
fold and legalize the activity
okay thank you when you say operators
you mean vendors vendors yeah so yeah
there's um Churchill Downs was one
they've ceased operations uh or
postponed
um there's one called TVG uh that does
it as well it's a it's a small niche
market currently they operate under a
gray area
um under a federal law called the
interstate horse racing Act of 1978
which they allege makes them legal we
don't believe it does rag said it's gray
why don't you fix it in the Statue so
that's why the law is put let's keep
going around the room and the other
question I had is in terms of where the
money goes for the problem gambling it
goes to that the council for a
responsible gambling so is that in
statute or is that in rules where where
is that
it's in the sports betting rules
statute statute yeah it's in the sports
building yeah yeah Statue yeah sorry
it's been so many times that has been
referenced in so many bills that have
passed this body I I lose track but yes
okay other hands up on this side of the
room representative Ames yep
time
I just wanted to make this point that uh
as we've talked about the issue of
problem gaming some some
uh numbers have been mentioned about the
number of gamblers out there uh and then
the incidents of responsible gaming I
just want to caution everyone
there's been a lot of research there's a
lot of data that is available I I I
don't want to
I don't want us to be walking away from
here thinking that there are 165 000
problem gamblers in New Hampshire I'm
not sure that's right I see director
McIntyre agreeing with me so maybe you
could uh speak on that well certainly so
um if there are a million adults giving
round numbers of the state about a
million adults we sold about half a
million of them a Powerball ticket last
year or two or three or more so that's
the largest product we have in terms of
breath
but it's very
because of the Velocity because the
drawings only every other third day
you can't play as often so problem
gamblers don't really go to Powerball
so the universe of problem gamblers who
do Powerball is very very low because it
doesn't happen very often whereas sports
betting is a very small Market
meaning we only have
about a hundred thousand registered
users at any given month we only have
between 30 and 50 000 people who access
the platform and that includes folks
about a state so you're talking in-state
problems if it's two percent sports
betting might be a higher because it's
velocity because you can play more often
there's always sporting events on and so
you have to sort of when you define
Gambler it's the Powerball player to a
sports bet or you know velocities which
I I've read literature which is a very
how accessible it is and also how often
you can play meaning can you play
immediately or could you have to wait
three days
will help Define if it's a problem or
not for the person because or create the
problem so I'd say the numbers probably
close to Fifteen twenty thousand people
in the state
maybe 15 000 would have maybe an issue
and based on the calls we get the
council gets it gets maybe a dozen two
dozen three dozen calls a month
but also for example we have the
DraftKings platform and our Lottery
platform have
um
functions that you can call in and say I
want to exclude myself because I have a
problem or whatever and those have
hundreds and hundreds of people
and I think the DraftKings platform
exceeds the thousand people now exclude
themselves we'll voluntary exclude
themselves and there are rare instances
but it does happen where a person will
have will use the call center
and use language which we believe is a
problem meaning I need to win this month
because of my mortgage payment and then
we will cancel their account
something like it hasn't happened often
but it happens and we will disable the
account for that problem so I would say
15 000 is probably a number you could
work with in terms of the state
uh representative almond
yes on
there have been for a long time we used
to be just scratch tickets
and there are people on there was one I
was told about by my convenience store
operator when I was getting my paper
there
many years ago who we we are across from
a ball bearing plant and every payday he
would come in and buy
80 scratch tickets
and then
stand there and open them until he'd run
out and then he'd go home with less
money to his wife
so that's
um
scratch so scratch tickets is something
that most people a lot of people in the
state do but a lot of people are only
doing
one for Christmas or
five for for a Christmas present or
something like that so
um
but it's really very difficult to
identify and and what we heard when we
were doing the casino work was that it's
um that a lot of gamblers that have a
major problem do and I think
representative leapley knows do not want
anybody to know
and are not willing to go and get help
because they're going to fix everything
with the next win
okay we have now spent quite a bit of
time on this
um I think the consensus correct me if
I'm wrong is that um no matter what this
bill needs more work right on the we
have two issues we have the breakage
definition and then we have
how do we handle the money and make sure
the money is going for proper uses
effectively
um so we are not going to exec this
today we have much more time to work on
this this is not an early build so we
have a little bit more time so we can
consider uh if you want to move your
Amendment later or if other people have
amendments so we have a little bit more
time or maybe the right thing to do as a
separate bill for some of these issues
representative only
I think it would be really important to
do this as a separate well conceived
bill but I think it would also be
helpful if we could get the woman that
is in charge
of
of this to come talk to us
since you really shouldn't be talking
about it correct I'll happily pass along
the message and I'll have her uh Madam
chair if it's okay I'll help her contact
you
um and that'll be the extent of my uh
but I will certainly pass along the
information in fact excellent we can we
can discuss whether that would be
um a work session on this bill or if
it's something we wanted to do
um separately I just have to think
through that the proper format to do
that but we will and it sounds like
there is a lot of interest in doing a
separate bill for next term
um so we'll continue to explore all
those options another hand was being
raised over there and there's your thing
representative Southworth I see it I see
it now
I apologize it is hard to see sometimes
in the corners
ah thank you
um just following up on your figure
which I appreciate of around 15
000 and following up on other comments
there's similar patterns with all the
different kind of addictions my sense
would be then you'd have a much smaller
number which might even be two or three
thousand but those are the much more
severe people who actually need much
more Intervention which is going to take
a chunk of the funds yeah it's a
difficult number to assess only because
it's it's also needs and um sort of
means based like I have a gentleman who
wages sports betting very large figures
very large but he owns a Gulf Stream
and so for him this is what he does for
fun and it's figures that would Astound
you but it's not a problem for him
because it's his he loves to do it and
he he can easily afford it so
um but yeah it's right if there's a
smaller percentage It's a larger problem
yeah thank you
other comments okay
um I guess we can close this and I
should mention that I'm involved in this
industry I wouldn't I'm not sure how
this would impact me but I am involved
in this industry
um but we will close the work session on
Senate Bill 112 and continue discussions
on that
okay so now we will open up and I forgot
I don't have a little gavel
we will now open up the public hearing
on Senate Bill 19 and we have a
non-germaine Amendment
number 1475 hopefully in your pile and I
will
take a moment to look at that
hold on hold on let me just see if I can
find it I left them both though there's
two amendments that I put a copy of each
and everyone's place
1475 and is also 1603.
okay let me just look see if I can find
it
yes okay just all right everyone has it
and um
okay so that we had heard that there
were some interesting amendments on this
bill
um we checked with the house clerk
um he thought it would be best to do a
non-germanian Amendment hearing so that
we could make sure we discuss this
publicly so representative Platt would
you like to go through
your amendments yes thank you uh and I
mentioned this two amendments 1603 as
well they both do the same thing but
different sections of the law so they
have to be at two different amendments
one's essentially 1603 is off of 14.75.
the Amendments simply allow Lucky Seven
to be applied over the same apply
allowed over the same 16 days that Bingo
would be allowed should this bill 16
Bill 19 FM become law the amendment
requires a separate hearing since this
house clerk ruled that the amendment
non-germain he did so because the
amendment starts wording an RSA 287 E21
was the original Bill concerned RSA 287
E6 same chapter in section but a
different subsection concerning Lucky
Seven rather than bingo I owed the
adoption of this amendment thank you and
going on to 1603 it was pointed out to
me by Rick Newman thank you very much
that this wording is twice in the
statute the statute may need
have the whole thing Rewritten and come
back to us for approval for the
executive rewrite but 1603 is a
different section of the same the same
wording so it was in there twice where
it was Lucky Seven was ten days we have
to change it to 16. till it's consistent
throughout
I actually do have a pink card from Rick
Newman so uh when when you're done
representative we'll ask him to come up
and help us
you all set yes okay great uh
representative
thank you madam chair uh representative
plett did you mean uh Amendment 1606
because that's what I have in front of
me not 1603.
she knows six is mine it looks like this
and it's different yeah oh oh another
one oh man 1603. no that's what you said
um
okay
okay and then we also have another
amendment representative Alma you have
an amendment as well so we have three
amendments so let's talk about them all
now and then we'll ask
um the person to testify but you want to
explain this to us
this came from Senator Susie and it was
introduced here by
um Cindy Senator Rosenwald and they I
through continually asking them I
finally got word backs that the Senate
on Republicans are fine that senator
avard in particular who is this Prime
sponsor on on
is approves of this amendment also
um
it was a little difficult because he was
traveling and Out of Touch
and his second was sick
is sick so
um
what it does is to just increase the
amount of money that the Charities
themselves can pay on
volunteers that have had to
take a long bus ride
on buy dinner
um
Maybe
pay for pens to bring for the for the
bingo game that kind of thing
um
that would
um that
the amount of money is in the bud in the
lead
law now as not to exceed twenty five
dollars
and 25 was put in quite a long time ago
and inflation has eaten into it and we
all have heard that they are having
trouble getting volunteers for the bingo
games they have to run with Volunteers
in Bingo and
um because of our law
and so they wanted to
get an increase up to 50 meaning that
the charity will get expense
statement from the volunteer and agree
with all her part of it and then pay
them whatever that was it doesn't mean
they get fifty dollars it means that
they get whatever their expenses that
the charity accepts would be
so that's all it does but it did seem to
me like a useful thing
to keep the bingo games going for the
people that still like to play Bingo and
like to socialize at bingo
I should just mention though that this
we are discussing it because we're
discussing this topic and we have
experts here but um this technically
probably would not be considered germane
because it isn't a different section of
the statute so we may have to actually
put that on the calendar for next week
when we exec it just to be fully
everyone aware of what's going on here
um but I thought it's important that we
discuss it yeah the clerk has gotten
quite rigorous all of a sudden yeah on
this particular issue yes as a operation
of a bingo game it always would have
been considered Germaine before but yeah
so we'll comply with whatever we need to
do
okay
um represent I should mention that I am
involved in this industry so I am
impacted by this bill uh Rick Newman
would you be available to come up and
testify
is there and if anyone else would like
to speak please fill out a pink card
thank you madam chair my name is Rick
Newman and uh representing the
uh
New Hampshire Association of charitable
gaming operators and I should also
mention uh I also represent the Spartans
Drummond bugle uh Corps out of Nashua
who originally uh I testified on on this
bill the original hearing just want to
focus on representative putz amendments
and to uh
reiterate what he said that these
amendments make the statute consistent
if you if you pass Senate Bill 19 to
allow um
bingo games to go from 10 to 16 days a
month
um these two amendments would allow a
sale of Lucky Seven to go from 10 to 16
days as well I think it's just really a
technical change
and I'm happy to answer any questions
no questions I don't think thank you so
much anyone else in the audience who
would like to discuss this
questions we have experts from Lottery
experts
okay
representative Phyllis yeah I'm just
wondering
um representative putt's Amendment
the 1603 has a whole section about the
dispensers
so are the dispensers already covered or
are is this com kind of
oh this is this isn't a
I think it's just reiterating existing
statute but just showing you the change
but it's it says that section
two
is a new sub paragraph
post three is not three is never mind
just forget forget I said that
yeah sometimes the way these amendments
are coming back is a little confusing in
my opinion it's the only change is to
change 10 days to 16 days in two places
for Lucky Seven period all else is doing
things a little bit differently this
year so it's getting a little caught up
with that
okay
is that it
seem no one else signed up yep go ahead
representative
Amendment representative Plus
over here
uh would this have to go back to the
Senate if it's amended or is it a
committee a conference it would go to
anytime we amend something then the
Senate can either concur non-concur or
request a committee of conference
other comments questions
testimony seeing none we will now close
the public hearing on Senate Bill 19
with Amendment
1475.
Madam chair should I limited to that or
did shall we cover 1603 as well I
believe 1603 as well because it is
related to that thank you yes that's
what I did
uh
1606 again we will do it we'll schedule
a public hearing on that
even for just five minutes just to make
sure we catch everyone who has a comment
on that uh and then
hopefully well maybe we'll be able to
execute next week we'll see again this
is not an early bill so we do have time
so you can look this over and see what
questions you have okay so we are now
I believe done for the day and we will
plan to reconvene next Tuesday
in the 9 A.M to 1
kind of range we're going to focus on
that to try to get things done and to
have be able to have all of you attend
thank you so much for being here today
next week yes so we're going to hear
this non-germaine amendment and then uh
unless we need to do any other work
sessions we will then go into an exec
session and of course each caucus may
break from time to time to discuss
things and where things are going but at
a minimum we will be taking out an exec
session for Senate bill 120.
because that is an early Bill and will
be absolutely under deadline okay so
just be prepared for that
thank you very much
we've got to save the one from school
now we're going to think about what
we're going to do next week so
um you actually you had two two pages
Democrats maybe we could get together
briefly
10 minutes
can we get together briefly for 10
minutes
to connect
exactly
okay an email as well
get over there
and then I'll figure this all out later
um